So it's my great pleasure to,
introduce Veronica Heimsback,
if if I pronounce
that correctly.
Heimsback. Yep. Okay.
Senior consultant in,
data science and AI,
insights and data
at, Capgemini,
who will be talking
about quite
a hot topic in our
space, shackle.
So over over to
you, Veronica.
Thank you, James. Okay.
Hello, everyone,
and welcome to
this talk on how
we can model requirements
described in regulations with
the shape constraint
language.
My name is Veronika Heinspak,
and I'm a senior consultant at
Capgemini in Norway.
I live, right outside of Oslo
with my fiancee and
our two children,
three year old Edward and one
year old Oda.
I got my degree
from the University
of Oslo with a specialization
in logic and semantics.
And, of work experience,
I've been touching
into stuff like,
writing kernel models in c to
semantic
technologies applications
in Java.
I started off as a developer,
but in two thousand
and nineteen,
I joined Capgemini.
And here I am working
as a semantics
nerd, information architect,
and advisor.
I have worked in
several different
industries, including oil,
life sciences, public
data, library,
and media.
I started working with Chacol
in two thousand
and sixteen, and,
yes, that is before it became
a standard.
And, as all nerds,
I have way too many
hobbies, like,
making stuff, hunting,
board games,
and teaching kids to
code to name a few.
So my current client
is the Norwich
Maritime Authority, and,
all the examples you'll see
today are actual data from our
current project,
simplified for
the sake of examples,
of course.
So let us have a look at our
simplified workflow
of the semantics
in the project.
We have several different
regulations in both Norwegian
and English as PDFs
or plain text.
And, some monkey
read me identifying
concepts and
relationships using
my highlighter pen in order to
transform the data into an owl
light ontology that
works as a term
bank. So it could
just be a discourse
taxonomy, for example,
and shackle constraints for
detailed instance modeling.
We have a sparkle
query library
that the back end use for
information
withdrawal that goes
through some processing before
it's pushed to the front end
application. And currently,
we have two
projects running in
parallel at the NMA.
The first one is called APS.
And, a brief
description of that
could be automatic
detection of
requirements connected to
certificates for sailors.
And the second
one is called ET
for short,
which describe metadata for
requirements and make use of
the graph as
an information lake
to ask for specific questions
connected to
the requirements.
An example of
a question could be,
my fishing vessel is
eight meters long,
and it's built
on January third
in nineteen ninety eight.
Give me all requirements that
apply for me in or order to
operate in a regional waters.
In this talk, I'll show you
examples from
the APS project.
So let us say we have a sailor
that wants to become a master
mountaineer.
There are then two
things you can do.
First, you could
use the sparkle
library to find
all requirements
needed for the master's minor
certificate. This information
is found in the shapes in
combination with the owl
light ontology.
And secondly,
we could take the sailor's CV
and requirement shape for this
certificate,
the master Maynard
certificate, as input.
And output will be
either conforms
true if and only
if he fulfills
the requirements needed for
the certificate or confirms
false if it does not.
If the output confirms false,
you'll get a report
from the shackle
engine telling you what,
the instance data,
the sailor's CV,
is missing in order to achieve
this certificate described in
the shapes.
So the data can
look like this.
And this is
the regulation text.
It's a plain text file where
someone must
identify classes,
relationships, and data values
by hand at the moment.
This is me and my highlight
highlighter pen
reading the region
regulation text and
using the English
version of the regulation to
translate on the fly.
We do actually have a proof of
concept running
right now to see
if it's faster to
identify these
entities with natural language
processing techniques.
And I'm quite sure that NLP is
much faster than me reading
stuff in an unknown domain as
I had no prior knowledge or
maritime data before I joined
this project. So
there's a there
have been a lot of funny
misunderstandings of
terms and concepts.
So we're going to model things
like this. So here we see
paragraph twenty
eight part two,
and it content describes
requirements for
gaining a master's
minor certificate.
And it says, in order to be
issued a competency
certificate,
decafusser class one,
that's the master
millionaire,
In addition to
the requirements
in paragraph twenty
three, twenty four,
twenty five, twenty six,
and twenty seven,
a minimum of thirty six months
seagoing service
as a responsible
deck officer on seagoing ships
with a gross tonnage of more
than five hundred
is required.
Seagoing service is reduced to
twenty four months if at least
twelve months are
earned as a chief
officer on a vessel of gross
tonnage five hundred or more.
Long sentences.
Anyways, as we see,
there is a lot of information
we want to keep
from this short
snippet of text,
and there is also alternatives
described here.
The first alternative
is minimum
thirty six months
as a deck officer,
where deck officer
is a superclass
for all kinds of deck
officer positions.
The second alternative
is minimum
of twenty four months
as a deck officer,
where at least twelve of those
is served as a chief officer.
And chief officer
is a subclass
of deck officer.
So how can we
handle alternatives
that includes
a lot of different
combinations and
relationships?
If we were to model this with
the web ontology language,
we sure would have
to touch into
owl axioms and restrictions at
some point.
We also need to know
if data is correct,
especially when
we are to compare
instance data with regulation
requirements. And AL can only
infer new facts in data,
but it can't discover
missing facts.
And being able to
understand OWL
axioms and how our
interpret data,
you will need
some understanding
of discrete mathematics
and logic.
Well, my client
are seafarers.
Even though some players at
the anime are trained in RDF,
that does not mean we should
throw high complexity
at the table
just because we can.
The data owners
here are experts
in their domain,
which is different and not in
semantic technologies.
The main language
we then chose
for a graph is
the shape constraint
language, a language designed
for validating RDF
under a closed
world assumption.
Unlike OWL, you
can confirm data
to given data constraints
with Jekyll,
which gives us the opportunity
of checking
a sailor's CV against
the set of requirements to see
if it fulfills a specific
certificate or not.
And, the shape
constraint language
are built up by shapes.
And a shackle shape
is a collection
of constraints for
a given RDF resource.
We have two kinds of
shapes in Shackle.
The first is a node shape that
describe constraints
about focus nodes,
usually the subject
of a triple,
and property shapes describing
constraints about
predicates and
object values of a triple.
The definition of a node shape
is that it is a shape that is
not the subject of a triple
where path is the predicate.
In this example,
we see a vessel shape that has
a constraint on
target class vessel.
So all constraints
following in
this shape will
have to do with
instances of
the class vessel.
The definition of a property
shape is that it is is a shape
that is the subject
of a triple
that has path as
its predicate.
In this example,
we see a length
shape with some
path to vessel length.
So for every occurrence
of the predicted
vessel length in any data,
the constraints described here
will apply to that triple.
We can add property
shapes onto
a node shape using
the resource
property. Here we
combine our true,
previous examples stating that
any instance of
the class vessel
may have some
relationship called
vessel length pointing
to, in this case,
some random object value as we
haven't any more detailed
constraints in
the property shape.
So there is a lot
of constraints
available in the Shackle core
constraint vocabulary,
and here is a brief
overview of
the main categories.
And the nice thing
about Shackle
is that if you don't
find a suitable
constraint for your problem,
you can extend
Chackle with your
own constraint definitions and
push them to
the web for others
to reuse if you like.
This is not
possible to do with
OWL as the OWL vocabulary is
limited to those resources set
by the OWL committee.
And, Schectel
contains constraints
about, value types as class
affiliation and
data type values,
cardinality as
min and max count
of predicates,
value range as min and max
inclusive and exclusive,
string based as
language checking,
regular expressions,
and length,
property pair,
comparing the object
value of two predicates,
logical constraints
as not, and,
and or,
Shape based as the property
relationship, we
have just seen
an example on.
And there is also a collection
of other constraints
that doesn't
fit into any of these
other categories.
And, there do exist
more categories
apart from the core,
like sparkle constraints and
check the advanced features,
but I will not cover those in
my talk today.
I can post the link
for the shackle
master class that was
hosted yesterday.
There are some
links to resources
and references
on things beyond
sparkle core available there.
So the main reason or one of
the main reasons
we chose Shackle
was because of the extensive
Shackle core
constraint vocabulary
and being able to extend that
that if needed.
Being able to
model requirements
containing
alternatives as easily
recognizable and
and or constraints
is a great benefit
for us at the anime.
Another reason is the verbose
description of
constraints that
makes it easier
for non semantic
players to read
the turtle files.
Unfortunately, there is no
currently no open
source tool,
at least to my knowledge,
that let us visually create
shackle constraints as protege
a does for OWL.
I know it exists
a shackle plugin
for protege, but
as far as I know,
or at least last time
I tried to use it,
it was,
only a circle code view inside
Prodigy and not the visual
modeling tool that
you know Progyny as.
So we would have to stick with
our editor of
choice if we want
to keep it open source.
And Chackle is a validation
language under closed
world assumption,
meaning that facts
that are not
known to be true are false.
And this is
necessary for us in
order to say
something about our
case for comparing CVs to
regulation requirements.
So let us take this example
snippet from the regulation.
How can we easily
express the requirement
that a vessel
shall have a gross
tonnage of at least
five hundred wells?
Like, this.
And here we have a property
shape describing
constraints for
a given predicate.
The predicate in question is
the value of half,
which is Gross Tonnage.
We have a constraint
that in a triple
where gross tonnage
is the predicate,
the object value
shall be minimum
or equal to five hundred.
We also have
a constraint telling
us the data type of
this object value,
which is unit g t,
and a min and max
count of one.
That means that the predicate
is unique and mandatory for
resources where it appears.
If vessel has a relationship
cross to some value,
this specific
relationship shall
only appear, once,
at least once and
not more than once.
And here we see
our solution on
how to model the alternatives
described in the regulation.
As we remember from paragraph
twenty eight part two,
there were two different
alternatives.
There are also,
some other options included in
this or constraint,
and I'm going to talk
you through it.
So the or constraint is a list
taking constraint that appears
at the predicate
position of a shape.
This or constraint
takes in two
and constraints as
its list elements.
The first and constraint are
the first alternative.
It takes in two
items in its list.
First, a or list of courses.
So at least one of
these courses,
courses must be present for
the whole expression
to be valid.
No. Not courses. Sorry.
It's certifications.
So the list of
certifications.
So at least one of these
certifications must be present
for the whole expression
to be valid.
And secondly, a specific value
for a seagoing service,
And we'll have a look a closer
look at this
seagoing service,
later on.
The second and constraints are
the second alternative.
It takes three
items in its list.
First, a or list
of certificates,
and then a specific value for
a seagoing service,
and another specific value for
a seagoing service.
We remember from
paragraph twenty
eight that the,
second alternative was twenty
four months as, some
in some position,
where at least twelve of those
months were in
another specific
position. And
that is described
in this second
and constraint.
So let us look at the rest of
the requirements
in the snippet.
We have information
about duration,
position, and a seagoing
relationship,
which can be some
kind of trade area,
the gross tonnage,
and the gross tonnage that we
saw in the previous example.
And here are the requirements
on the previous slide that
described as shapes.
The first shape is similar to
the one for gross to Nash,
describing a minimum or equals
constraint. The second,
state that the predicate in
position shall be any instance
of a decoder position.
At last, we have a property
shape describing the predicate
trade area to have a specific
value of bank phishing.
The plus hierarchy with labels
and relationships is found in
the owl light ontology
at the moment.
However, this
information could
as well be in
the shapes instead.
At the NMA,
they already had a few owl
ontologies for
their domain when
I joined the project,
but they struggled a lot,
with how to model
the alternatives
described in
the regulation and
applying information like mean
inclusive and data values.
And that is another
of the main
reasons why I proposed model
requirements in
Chacel as it is
so verbose and concrete.
And for this case,
on comparing CVs
and regulation
requirements, it's
also the perfect
case for Shackle validation.
So let us put it all together
for our first alternative in
paragraph twenty
eight part two.
We have a node
shape describing
the class value of this first
alternative using the property
shape constraints
that we just saw.
And some good
good annotation,
shape description is a must.
And then we target the class
that represent the first kind
of seagoing service described
in the paragraph,
which is the the value
for target class.
And at last, we
connect the necessary
property shapes
with constraints
that apply to this kind of
seagoing service.
The constraints for
duration, position,
trade area, and
gross to match.
So what Checkl really does for
our models is it allows us to
model data with a closed world
assumption. This means that we
strive for completeness
of our data,
and we do not
admit that we have
any incomplete
knowledge in our
regulations. And
that is the whole
point of a regulation,
isn't it?
A regulation is a set of
requirements for one specific
subdomain of
maritime authorities
in the region waters in this
particular project.
And it is important
to remember
that with the web ontology
language and the open
world assumption,
we can describe
broader and more
unknown domains that makes it
easier to apply
ontologies across
various applications
and domains.
However, even though shackle
under a closed
world assumption
is probably most
powerful locally,
it is possible to reuse and
share constraints
across several
application, especially in
combination with existing
ontologies using
them as a reference
for your constraints.
If you're reusing
shackle shapes
from another application,
you have the possibility of
deactivating shapes that it's
irrelevant for
your application
and add new ones that apply in
order to extend
the shapes graph
you're reusing.
With shackle, we
can handle any
constraint. And
if we don't find
what we need in
the shackle core,
you can simply
add it yourself.
You can even push your new
constraints to
the web for others
to reuse.
And shackle is
verbose and gives
us detailed explanation
of requirements,
which is really
handy for players
with limited
experience with RDF.
And again,
OWL and RDFS are splendid on
inferencing missing facts.
However, it is not detecting
missing data, and that
is what we need.
Would would you
like to go over
to questions now? Sure.
You'll be pleased to know it's
been relentless, the,
the number of questions.
So I'll try and rewind back to
some of some of
the earlier ones.
What are
the hardware requirements
to use Shackle as
a validation language?
Do you need a reasoner,
data storage,
etcetera?
It depends on your application
and what you
already have, but,
you can do Shackle validation
in memory if you
like without,
having to use
a graph database.
So, you have several different
shackle implementations ready
in frameworks for programming
languages as Java, c
sharp, and Python.
I'm most familiar
with the Java
frameworks, and I know that
the the two most
popular frameworks,
which is RDFJ and Jena,
doesn't support
the full shackle
implementation yet.
But it's possible
to use it for
for the most
popular constraints
in the shackle core.
And by using
a programming framework,
you won't need a database.
There is also
shackle implementations
in graph databases.
As StarDog,
they have a implementation of
the shackle core constraints.
And also, top
quadrant actually
have a full shackle
implementation,
including the shackle
advanced features.
And that is probably
because one
of the employees at
Top Quadrant is,
one of the leading developers
on this standard. Yes.
Apart from that,
I don't know if
I see there was
a question on Neo four
j or AVS Neptune.
I'm not familiar with,
if Neo four j has
an implementation
of Shackle.
I'm not sure because Neo four
j is operating on other data
than than RDF.
It's on labeled perfect graphs
and not semantic
knowledge graphs.
But I know they
try to map their
labeled property
graphs onto RDF
and vice versa.
So if there exists
some shackle
implementations
in Neo four j,
I don't know, but it would be
funny to see. Yeah.
I shared, I shared a link.
So they have they have
an implementation
of shackle, but
I think it's it
relies on transforming RDF to
label property graph,
and then it's,
it's part of an internal kind
of Java plug in, I think,
some of the validation
functionality.
There was a question or some
points around shackle
c versus shackle.
I'm not sure whether
that's a thing
maybe might want
to elaborate on.
I don't know
whether that makes
any sense. I'm
not familiar with
shackle c. No. No.
No. Not me neither.
I'm sorry. It's a typo. Okay.
It was Yeah.
It it may look like shape
expressions that,
has been kind of
a schema language
for RDF prior to Shackle,
but I'm not too
familiar with that.
So, someone Yeah.
Someone commented
Shackle compact
syntax is Okay. Okay.
That's that's his one.
That has to do with Jason Aldi
probably because that can be
compacted quite a bit. Okay.
There was another question,
about whether it's possible to
model you may have already
answered this, but,
whether it's possible to model
shackle constraints completely
via sparkle queries.
Yes. All shackle
constraints can
be translated to
sparkle at least.
And I'm not sure if you can do
it the other way
by constructing
shackle from sparkle.
I haven't tried it.
But in the shackle
documentation,
on the w three c domain,
every single shape
constraint has a,
a sparkle definition as well.
So So you can go in there and
look on the sparkle definition
for every single constraint.
I'm sure it probably
is possible
to turn it the other
way around
as well if you
want to construct
shapes using, sparkle.
Okay. Great.
There was a question
also from,
Vladimir Alexiev,
asking, Veronica,
have you considered generating
shackle from a briefer
logical notation?
Your rules are
reminiscent of prologue.
No. I I haven't
considered that,
but, I'll, bear it
with me. Thank you.
Cool. Maybe maybe
you guys can,
connect in the, in
the Slack channel.
Yeah.
Great. Are there,
any other questions?
I can see a few
people typing.
So, I'll just
check back through
the history of the questions
whilst that's those
are coming through.
I guess whilst,
whilst those
questions are coming
through, I, yeah,
I have a real
affinity for the the
kind of language
challenge in,
shipping. So we, we
do a lot of work.
My company does a lot of work
in shipping.
And the the language
the language
is particularly
unique, isn't it?
And there's very
little in the way
of kind of industry
standards,
particularly kind
of ontologies
or at least from
from what we've
found anyway.
So I guess I was interested in
how you're applying
Shackle for
kind of unstructured versus
structured data,
whether you're
using Shackle for
you touched on kind of maybe
some opportunities
around NLP and,
Yeah. Yes.
The NLP proof of concept was
started because
I didn't bother
to spend too much
time on reading
the regulation text.
It's about, I believe,
around seventy regulations in
the Norwich marathon sources.
And, translating manually one
text to anthology
or two shuffle
shapes by hand took probably
around a week. So that's time
consuming and expensive
for my client.
So we wanted to try out to see
if we could make use of some
simple NLP techniques to,
draw information
from the text.
So we have
actually successfully
generated all
scope descriptions
and requirements descriptions
connected to those scopes.
And one scope
could be like a a
value range for vessel length
or a date before and after one
certain date or
machine power.
And a lot of different things
are scopes in in the text.
So we successfully
do that now.
And, the most challenging task
around that is classifying
entities discovered in text to
be of kind material
or construction
or equipment and
stuff like that.
And so, yeah,
the the proof of concept is
still running.
It's supposed to
be finalized during
December, and,
hopefully, we will
get the result
that we want, which
is the the class
hierarchy or taxonomy,
including labels
and the the the
shapes describing requirements
and and scopes for the data.